brown began to shake
32 million people here in tokyo braced
themselves for the worst
8.9 magnitude now we know that's a big
number was the fifth largest earthquake
in history
[Applause]
but the real damage comes from the
ferocious tsunami that was unleashed
in some areas the waves reached 40
meters in height sweeping up
everything in its path including cars
and ships unable to withstand the
strength and the power of the surging
water
japan is located in the pacific
earthquake belt
this means the country is struck by some
of the strongest earthquakes and
tsunamis in the world
in the past decade about 30 tropical
storms have also hit the country each
year these natural disasters kill on
average 100 to 200 people per year
and take a huge toll on the country's
economy
but learning from painful experience
japan has built one of the world's best
natural disaster response systems
which includes regular disaster
preparedness drills
and early warning alerts japanese
engineers and architects have also
pushed the boundaries of technology and
design
to create resilient disaster-proof
buildings
this is tokyo skytree at 634 meters
it's the world's tallest tower designed
for broadcasting and observation
the base of skytree occupies a
relatively small plot of land
that isn't ideal for such a tall
structure and a designer
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
designed a steel truss tower so instead
of fighting against the wind
it can simply pass through the gaps
between the trusses
to stabilize the tower the team used a
traditional japanese design called
shimboshira
that dates back over a thousand years
this is the flexible central pillar of a
japanese pagoda
which stabilizes the tiered wooden
structure during an earthquake or
typhoon
in a similar way to a tree trunk
supporting its branches
a shimbushira has been found at the
center of the world's oldest wooden
structure
made from a tree filled in 594ad
for skytree the team designed a 375
metre tall concrete core column
connected to the tower's steel outer
frame by a series of flexible
oil dampers devices that control
unwanted vibrations
the swaying of the core column and outer
frame in opposite directions
reduce the vibration of the entire tower
by up to 50
during an earthquake and 30 percent
during strong winds
[Music]
the core column is set on six seismic
isolators made of rubber
these absorb unwanted movement and work
together with the oil dampers at various
heights
the top part of skytree is a
broadcasting antenna
to ensure high quality the antenna needs
to stay as stable as possible
so two tuned mass damper systems were
installed to reduce unwanted vibrations
one is set at an altitude of 625 meters
and weighs 25 tonnes and the other is at
an altitude of 620 meters
and weighs 40 tons when the tower shakes
these two dampers act together as
reverse pendulums
reducing vibrations caused by wind or an
earthquake
[Music]
when skytree was designed in the late
2000s architects and engineers flew
weather balloons
to collect data on wind speeds and build
models which they tested in a wind
tunnel
but for some building designs this
expensive and time-consuming process
has been replaced by faster and cheaper
software powered by artificial
intelligence
after a decade of research architectural
engineering company takenaka
has developed a typhoon simulation
software called casimidori
[Music]
[Music]
for a foreign kilometer square urban
area it usually takes three months to
build a model
conduct a wind tunnel test and get the
results but with taki naka's software
the entire process can happen in just
two or three days
and its engineers are trying to reduce
that down to half a day
[Music]
[Music]
japanese architects are also
experimenting with unconventional
building materials for high-rises
skyscrapers are usually built from
concrete or steel because they're strong
and cost effective
but building from wood is more
environmentally friendly
compared with the production of steel
and concrete production of timber
consumes less energy and releases less
carbon dioxide
new trees can also be planted to absorb
emissions
but building tool structures with wood
offers up its own engineering and
financial challenges
that didn't stop japanese construction
company maida
office building in tokyo shibuya
district
to make the building earthquake proof
designers came up with a hybrid lattice
structure
that will support the walls and create a
more user-friendly experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these designs and technologies have
helped high-rise buildings to withstand
typhoons and earthquakes
and now many low-rise buildings in japan
are starting to adopt them as well
some vulnerabilities still exist like
older buildings constructed before
regulations were tightened in 1981
with natural disasters becoming more and
more frequent
these innovative designs and
technologies could be key to protecting
the economy and lives
both in japan and around the world
you